let's talk a little bit about the u.s
customary units for distance if we go to
a human scale the most typical used unit
in the u.s customary system would be the
foot
and as you can imagine the term foot and
if you have many of them you are now
talking about feet comes from the same
word on the human body we have a foot or
we have two we have two feet
now not everyone's feet are the same
length but the length of a foot is
roughly a little bit larger than most
people's feet and there are definitely
peoples who there are definitely people
whose feet are the size of a foot and if
you're in the u.s you've probably heard
of people measuring their height in
terms of feet so for example a a
slightly above average
a man
of slightly above average height would
have a height of six feet so for example
right over here if this gentleman right
over here was slightly above average
height his height might be six feet and
that might also be his wingspan so it
would be a distance something like that
if you wanted to measure things that are
a little bit smaller say smaller than a
foot or if you wanted to measure parts
of a foot then you would go to the inch
then you would go
to the inch and the relationship between
the foot and the inch is at 12 inches
12 inches
are equal to 1
are equal to 1 foot so for example this
little mouse right over here it might be
reasonable to measure it in inches on
this scale an inch an inch might be
might be something like
might be well depending on the size of
the mouse an inch might be something
like that it's also useful for measuring
things like human height because very
few people are a whole number of feet
they're usually some fraction of feet so
for example for example i am
feet
and 9 inches
and sometimes this is denoted as 5 and
you have this you have this apostrophe
here one apostrophe and then five foot
nine inches and this is two apostrophes
kind of saying hey you're going the next
unit down this is the these are the
inches right over here
now if you want to go to things that are
larger than maybe human scale ue have
units for that as well including the
yard
the yard is equal to 3 feet
is equal to 3 feet and 3 feet well each
foot is 12 inches so this is the same
thing as 36
inches and this is most typically used
for measuring uh
measuring distances of a lot of some
kind and in in the united states most
famously for in football so your
regulation size football field the
playing field the distance between the
end zones is exactly is exactly 100 i
know you can't see my writing there is
exactly 100
100 yards
is
100 yards is this distance
this distance right over here right
between the end zones
now if you want to measure even longer
distances that's where we go to the mile
we go to
the mile
and all of these units are our ancient
units going back actually thousands of
years and the mile based on the reading
i found was even used in roman times and
actually that's some of the first as far
as some of the first examples of the of
of this term being used and it was it
really comes from the same root word as
a thousand of meal of a thousand
footsteps of a roman soldier and now a
standard mile is exactly five thousand
two hundred and eighty feet five
thousand
two hundred and eighty five thousand two
hundred and eighty feet and if you
wanted to figure out this in inches you
could just multiply by 12. but just get
a sense of a mile here's a mile on this
map of new york
so there's parts so if you wanted to put
it right onto manhattan this distance
right over here this distance right over
here
is about a mile so you want to measure
really far distances either from one
point in a city to another or maybe even
the distance between cities or maybe
even the the size of the planet or even
the distance from the earth to the moon
or something like that
you will hear that referenced in miles
even the distance between the earth and
the sun people say it's 93 million miles
if you're talking about maybe a plot of
land you want to measure its dimensions
or you're talking about a football field
then yards feel appropriate
if you're kind of getting to human scale
well human scale on one level but you
could get a little bit larger if maybe
you're talking about the height of a
building or something like that or
you're still talking about measurements
of of say a plot of land you will still
hear people talk in terms of feet
and if you're measuring either parts of
a foot or things that are smaller than a
foot that's when inches come into play